homeowners lined up at local tax offices
to take advantage of a deduction before
it changes starting January 1st state
and local tax deductions are capped at
$10,000 the IRS says that some
homeowners who prepay their property
taxes can avoid this limit it will
depend though on when their property is
assessed CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here with whether it
makes sense to prepay your property
taxes and how to take advantage of that
stock market surge the president was
talking about in the new year Jill great
to see you so we're in the stock market
in just a second but what should people
be considering when they're deciding
whether or not they should prepay their
taxes
I think the first thing is pull last
year's tax returns out so you have a
reference and your big question is will
I be an Itemizer next year or will I
claim that nearly doubled standard
deduction twelve thousand as an
individual twenty four thousand as a
couple and if you are going to be an
Itemizer next year more than the twenty
four thousand level then you look and
say okay now am I actually looking at
those deductions totaling more than ten
thousand dollars total again it's state
and local income tax as well as your
property tax now that doesn't leave a
ton of people but there are some high
tax states where you know it might fall
into that if that's all the case and you
want to say hey let me prepay that
remember that number one prepaying it
may thrust you into this alternative
minimum tax scenario where you might not
actually see the benefit number two
yesterday the IRS released a new warning
which said that property tax had better
been assessed and billed for you to
prepaid okay so lots of caveats if your
accountant is still in town because it
is so confusing honestly and you know
it's trying to walk my mother's
boyfriend through this one either way
and I was like okay you've done this
have you done this and he is in line at
the taxing authority and says okay I
think I know and I said by the way this
may not work it's true with this new tax
legislation accountants are working
overtime but if there any time left to
file this year given that they're only
two days left in the year well there's
two days so you could but again you've
got to have that tax bill it had to have
been asset
and build otherwise the IRS says they're
not going to count it I think a lot of
the professionals that I'm speaking to
CPAs certified financial planners are
saying look if you're gonna itemize next
year and you're gonna have a whole bunch
of itemized deductions that go way over
and be discounted you might as well try
for this year and see what happens
because it won't work next year changes
that we're seeing in the tax law though
how is that going to affect the housing
market well you know we are starting to
see some murmurs of people who believe
in the housing industry that will we'll
start to see a big pullback in prices
maybe by as much as 10% in some of these
high tax states that said oftentimes
when we have tax changes the overtime
the the effect is minimized and we don't
see that big pullback lasting for a long
time look what's going to be more
important about the housing market is
will there be jobs is the economy
growing and by the way how's that stock
market going well let's talk about the
stock market as you know we've talked
about this before 2017 was a tremendous
year for the stock market the president
reminds the American people on a regular
basis it has been strong over the last
several years but what are you looking
at going forward well I think that there
were three things that really propelled
the market this year we had global
growth it was synchronistic everything
happened at once and it really actually
unimaginable when we look back just a
year ago so things were good around the
globe corporations made a lot of money
corporate profitability was up and
interest rates remain low that was the
main driver of the market this year I
will also say of course the tax bill
helped and the loosening of regulations
in certain industries all of this comes
into 2018 and it looks like we sort of
have the wind at our backs for the stock
market but that said things can change
really quickly and I would never want
someone to bet everything on the stock
market we still want you to be
diversified investors and be really
smart about how a bit disingenuous
though for the president to say that
most Americans are benefitting from the
stock market run-up because most
Americans don't own individual stocks
yeah I mean over half by the way and we
look at and say the ownership of stocks
directly ownership of stock stock mutual
funds even pension plans 54% of
Americans own that boy that leaves a lot
of people who don't own it and
by the way that starts to really help
people understand why the middle-class
people who maybe had to blow out of
their retirement accounts during the
recession or maybe had a reduction in
income are still feeling the pain of the
Great Recession and also feeling the
pain of the last 20 years where wages
have essentially remained stagnant once
you account for inflation so it is fair
to say the stock market's gone up a lot
it's also fair to say that a good
portion of Americans have not
participated all right Jill Schlesinger
great advice all across the board thank
you thank you